[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's not about drugs it's a dope song
don't do drugs can't believe how big you
here Gabe got a boat he's kidding right
he's not kidding hey I think it's about
that clock oh yeah where's Jason
[Music]
what were you I didn't know if you were
lost stick with me I'll keep you safe
[Music]
there's a family our driveway it's
probably the neighbors John Scavo family
how can I help you sir if you want to
get crazy we can get crazy
[Applause]
they look exactly like us they think
like us they know where we are
to move and keep moving
they won't stop until they kill us and
we kill them
okay let's call the cops I did there 14
minutes away what 14 minutes okay okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay
Justin give me the bat the baseball bat
the bat there's one in the club yeah
thank you
hold on let's try this again oh all
right
yes I got this
I thought I already done told y'all to
get off my property
okay so if y'all want to get crazy we
can get crazy not a cop's already on day
way hey hey hey hey hey
you know how sometimes things line up
yeah you know like coincidences since
we've been here they've been happening
more and more I think I feel like it
means like she's getting closer hmm you
don't believe me I I do I do I'm
processing okay I just can't believe you
kept all this inside for so long you
know I'm here right
so someone outside probably the
neighbors put your shoes on can I help
you
this is an intense and all-consuming
film to be a part of Jordan has this way
of creating terrifying moments are you
people it was it was very scary for me
to play both the hero and the villain
and to pursue both of their objectives
stick with me I don't keep you safe
Jordan was so awesome because there's
just no limit to how weird you can get
how crazy you see how incredibly
entertaining it is what he does and
brutally scary
Jordan appeal movies are so different
you can never tell what's about to
happen and that's what I'm always
wanting in a horror movie
you're just joining a really creative
brilliant mind who trusts you to help
augment the world that he's created
Jordan is making his favorite movie all
the time so that passion you know that
kind of enthusiasm is infectious I would
work with him again and again and again
[Music]